El pasado 26 de noviembre de 2017 hubo elecciones
en Honduras, elecciones un tanto particulares:
aunque millones de personas estaban llamadas
a votar ese día, al final solo contó un
voto… El del presidente, Juan Orlando Hernández,
que decidió quedarse otros cuatro años más,
dijeran lo que dijeran las urnas.
Sí, vamos, que es muy posible que el Presidente
Hernández se dijese a sí mismo: “Oye,
si a mí me gusta esto de ser Presidente…
¿por qué dejarlo?
No, no, algo habrá que hacer”.
Desde entonces las protestas, ante lo que
todo apunta ha sido un pucherazo, un robo,
un asalto a la democracia, se han sucedido
con bastante intensidad.
En un país, Honduras, que ya de por sí sufre
como pocos las trágicas consecuencias de
un modelo social y político cocinado con
mucha corrupción y mucha violencia.
Un modelo tan desastroso y disfuncional
que ha hecho que Honduras, sea el país, ojo,
más pobre de Latinoamérica y el tercer país
no en guerra más peligroso del mundo.
Veréis, Honduras es un pequeño país tropical,
con poco más de 9 millones de habitantes
situado en un estrecho trozo de tierra que
separa el Mar Caribe del Océano Pacífico.
Sí, para que nos entendamos, Honduras es
uno de esos lugares en los que podemos encontrar
algunas de esas playas que todos tenemos grabadas
en nuestra imaginación.
Playas de arena blanca, agua cristalina y
muchos cocoteros.
Suena bien, ¿verdad?
Desgraciadamente, amigos, el narcotráfico,
las pandillas y una élite política y económica
que han priorizado, por encima de todo, el
saqueo de los recursos nacionales, han enturbiado,
manchado la realidad de un país que de otra
forma podría estar, seguro, luchando por
ser considerado un auténtico paraíso en
la tierra.
Pero bien, puede que estéis pensando.. un
país pequeño, remoto, pobre… bueno…
una historia más, una historia de tantas
otras ¿verdad?
Pues, esperad un momento porque aquí hay
mucho, pero que mucho más.
¿Qué pensariais si os digo que es posible
que estemos ante el primer golpe de estado
apoyado por la Administración Trump?
Atentos.
EL FRAUDE
El domingo 26 de diciembre de 2017 se celebraron
elecciones generales en Honduras.
A la Presidencia, el cargo con diferencia
más importante, hubo, fundamentalmente, dos
grandes contendientes:
Por una lado, el Presidente Juan Orlando Hernández
que, apoyado ampliamente por la cúpula económica
del país y también, por la comunidad internacional,
aspiraba a ser reelegido.
Una reelección que, por cierto, ha sido muy
polémica, porque en principio la Constitución
del país la impede en su artículo 239;
un artículo que en 2015 fue declarado inaplicable
por un fallo sorprendente y muy, pero que
muy controvertido de la Corte Suprema.
Un órgano que por cierto está “controlado”
por el Presidente.
Sí, puede que eso haya tenido algo que ver.
Atentos a lo que decía este artículo 239:
“El ciudadano que haya desempeñado la titularidad
del Poder Ejecutivo no podrá ser presidente
o designado”.
Bien, por otro lado, Salvador Nasralla, un popular presentador de televisión que  se
postuló como candidato de una coalición
de partidos de centro izquierda, la Alianza de Oposición.
Pues bien, el caso es que en los momentos
iniciales del recuento de votos, todo apuntaba
a la victoria de Salvador Nasralla. Fijaos.
(Con casi el 60% del voto escrutado, lograba
una diferencia de 5 puntos sobre el Presidente.
Una ventaja tan contundente que los propios
magistrados que forman el Tribunal Supremo
Electoral de Honduras calificaron esta situación
ante los representantes de la Organización
de Estados Americanos como irreversible, insalvable.)
Sin embargo, de repente, el recuento se paró,
se dejaron de tener datos, los sistemas informáticos
se cayeron, aparecieron papeletas por contar
y al final… varios días más tarde… el
Tribunal electoral le otorgó la victoria,
sorpresa, al Presidente Juan Orlando Hernández.
Las irregularidades fueron tantas que la propia
Organización de Estados Americanos ha rechazado
el recuento y ha pedido
nuevas elecciones.
Pero ahí no termina todo.
El semanario The Economist, publicó en su
página web un día antes de las elecciones
que tenía una grabación que acreditaba que
el gobierno se estaba preparando para ganar o ganar.
En fin, ¿hubo pucherazo?
es difícil asegurarlo, pero las probabilidades
de que esto ocurriese son muy, pero que muy
altas.
Todo ello por no hablar del comportamiento
autoritario que el gobierno ha tenido.
Claro, una vez que la sospecha de amaño electoral
estaba sobre la mesa, la oposición pues se
movilizó y organizó concentraciones de protesta.
En un primer momento fueron pacíficas, algo
que no le importó a la policía para emplear
la mano más dura.
(Por ejemplo, la noche del miércoles 29,
las fuerzas del estado lanzaron gases lacrimógenos
sobre una concentración de unas 1000 personas
que estaban esperando pacíficamente los resultados
y en la que se encontraba el candidato opositor
Salvador Nasralla.
A la polícia no le importó que fuese una
concentración pacífica ni que hubiese niños
y personas mayores.)
Bueno, el gobierno
incluso decretó el toque de queda, y desde
entonces las concentraciones se han saldado
según las informaciones de Amnistía Internacional
con la pérdida de 14 vidas y más de 800
detenidos.
Vamos, en otras palabras, las pruebas parecen
apuntar a un claro pucherazo electoral, seguido
de un proceso represión y uso de la fuerza
para apuntalar esta victoria.
Ahora bien, dicho es, tenemos varias preguntas
por contestar.
Y una de ellas, claramente es ¿Quién es
exactamente el Presidente?
¿Quién es Juan Orlando Hernández?
EL PRESIDENTE
Hay dos versiones, dos interpretaciones muy
diferentes sobre la figura del Presidente
Juan Orlando Hernández.
La primera es la de un líder con mano dura
pero que fue capaz de rescatar a su país
de convertirse en un estado fallido.
La segunda, es la de un líder autoritario,
vinculado con la corrupción y el crimen,
un líder que se ha hecho con el control de
las instituciones del país y las maneja a
su antojo conforme a sus intereses.
Cómo hemos visto con la Corte Suprema y la
reelección.
Sin embargo, el Presidente, luego lo veremos
con más detalle, tiene el apoyo entre otros
de Estados Unidos.
Y para ser justos, hay que decir que su mandato
ha tenido muchas sombras, pero también algunas luces
Empecemos con estas, con las luces.
Fijaos, cuando Juan Orlando Hernández llegó
al poder en 2013, Honduras era el país no
en guerra con la tasa de homicidios más alta,
Honduras era el país no en guerra más mortífero
del mundo.
Hoy, es verdad, el país sigue teniendo un
grave problema, sigue siendo el tercer país
con más homicidios en relación a su población
y el 90% de los crímenes permanecen impunes.
Pero la cosa ha mejorado.
De hecho, eso es practicante el logro por
el que esté Presidente saca pecho.
(Con la ayuda de los Estados Unidos, el gobierno
hondureño creó nuevos cuerpos especiales
de policía, financiados, equipados y entrenados
por la DEA y el FBI entre otros cuerpos.
Al mismo tiempo ha expulsado y reemplazado a
miles de agentes corruptos, ha desmantelado
varios cárteles de la droga y extraditó
a decenas de narcotraficantes a Estados Unidos.
Incluso ha creado por todo el país parques
vigilados por la policía militar para que
niños y familias puedan disfrutar del tiempo
libre con cierta seguridad.)
Hasta aquí todo bien ¿Verdad?
Desgraciadamente, amigos, la historia no termina
así.
Hay pruebas claras de la corrupción del Presidente.
De hecho, la campaña electoral de 2013 que
le llevó al poder fue financiada por dinero
sustraído ni más ni menos que del Instituto
Hondureño de la Seguridad Social.
E incluso, sí, hay sospechas fundadas de
que el presidente Orlando ha tenido relación
con grupos de narcotraficantes, como “Los
Cachiros”.
“El comercio ilícito de drogas en Honduras
no solo afectó a gran parte de la sociedad
civil e incluso a los niveles más altos del
gobierno y el sector financiero, sino que
también permitió que su gente quedara expuesta
a terribles niveles de violencia”
En cualquier caso, sean o no ciertas estas
acusaciones,  y ahora me dirigió a usted
señor Presidente:
la represión, el engaño y el control de
las instituciones ni pueden justificarse ni
contribuyen a que Honduras pueda superar los
problemas que impiden su desarrollo.
Usted ha tenido un apoyo claro de la comunidad
internacional, ha recibido dinero, ayuda policial,
militar y respaldo político.
Y, la verdad, creo que se esperaba algo distinto.]
Claro que, amigos, desgraciadamente todo esto
no es algo extraño en este país.
UN CÓCTEL DE CORRUPCIÓN Y VIOLENCIA
Honduras tiene un problema muy difícil de combatir:
Existe un triángulo de poderes interrelacionándose
que hacen que en Honduras ser optimista sea
un reto difícil: el poder político, la oligarquía
económica y los narcos.
Tal vez el caso más representativo de todos
sea el de Fabio Lobo, el hijo de Porfirio
Lobo el anterior Presidente de la República,
que acaba de ser condenado en Estados Unidos
a 24 años de cárcel por sus vínculos y
actividades como narcotraficante.
Unas actividades que desempeñó cuando su
padre era, atentos, el mismísimo Presidente
de la República.
[Y no, no hablamos de un hijo rebelde ni nada
por el estilo].
Por cierto, el narcotráfico es hoy la primera
actividad económica de Honduras.
Otro ejemplo, tal y como cuenta el New York
Times, está en el Parlamento, en el Congreso.
Un edificio de los años 50, infraequipado,
que carece de las mínimas condiciones necesarias
y que contrasta con el parking de los señores
diputados, el estacionamiento está lleno
de vehículos todoterreno, último modelo
y carísimos.
Y esto afecta a prácticamente todos, a los
diputados del gobierno y de la oposición.
La policía y los cuerpos de seguridad tampoco
se salvan.
Las extorsiones y las mordidas son habituales
e incluso son ampliamente conocidos los lazos
de miembros de la policía con pandillas y
narcos.
“Los pandilleros de la Mara Salvatrucha
en Rivera Hernández dicen que la policía
les avisa de redadas inminentes y les entregan
a rivales capturados para que los ejecuten,
a cambio de un monto que va de 440 a 2.200
dólares por cabeza.”
Sonia Nazario, periodista estadounidense ganadora
del Premio Pulitzer.
Políticos, cuerpos de seguridad, pandillas,
narcos… y por último la oligarquía económica.
(Diez familias que controlan prácticamente
todos los recursos económicos y no han tenido
problemas en pagar sobornos y situar en los
poderes políticos a personas de confianza
para generar no un modelo de mercado, ojo,
sino un modelo que vive del control de las
instituciones.)
Pues bien, todos ellos amigos, forman un entramado
muy extractivo de recursos y tienen la responsabilidad
de que Honduras no sea ese paraíso en la
tierra que comentamos al principio de este vídeo.
Pero antes también mencionamos al gobierno
de Estados Unidos, a la Administración Trump
como un posible responsable de lo que ha ocurrido
con las elecciones en Honduras.
Así que, a ello.
EL PESO DE WASHINGTON
Aparentemente podríamos pensar que Honduras
bueno, no es un país nada importante para
Washington ¿Verdad?
Pues… no exactamente.
Lo cierto es que Honduras tiene cierto peso
en Estados Unidos, y lo tiene por 3 razones principales:
primero porque una gran parte de los vuelos
sospechosos de transportar droga desde Sudamérica
tienen su primera parada en este país.
Segundo, porque hace dos años ante la enorme
crisis que vivía el país 18.000 niños hondureños
que viajaban solos llegaron a la frontera
de Estados Unidos.
Y en Washington nadie quiere que cosas así
se repitan.
Tercero, porque tradicionalmente Honduras
ha sido un país aliado, de hecho aquí Estados
Unidos tiene desde hace décadas una base
militar.
Es por todo ello, que la potencia norteamericana
ha gastado en los últimos años cientos de
millones de dólares en Honduras para tratar
de revertir los problemas del país.
Pues bien, en la Administración Trump, lo
tienen claro, apoyan a Juan Orlando Hernández.
Atentos a estas palabras de un destacado asesor
republicano:
“Washington ha invertido dinero significativo
en Centroamérica para ayudar a cambiar la
seguridad y la situación económica.
Si Hernández pierde las elecciones, los Estados
Unidos no tendrán socios efectivos en la
región, la efectividad de nuestros miles
de millones de dólares estaría en riesgo,
y más gente podría estar tentada a venir
a los Estados Unidos".
Sí, el apoyo de Washington es claro.
De hecho, la policia entrenada y financiada
por Estados Unidos ha participado en los sucesos
post electorales sin queja alguna de la embajada
estadounidense.
Y es que el gobierno norteamericano también
tiene cierto temor a los lazos que la candidatura
de Salvador Nasralla podría llegar a tener
con el régimen cubano o incluso con la Venezuela
de Nicolás Maduro, algo que por cierto el
candidato niega tajantemente.
“Se equivocan porque mi modelo es la izquierda
moderada de Uruguay o de Chile, o la derecha
moderada de Costa Rica.
Una cosa es la amistad que mi socio ideológico,
Luis Zelaya, tiene con Maduro o Morales y
otra cosa es lo que pienso yo que seré el
presidente”.
En fin amigos, para todos los que nos veáis
desde Honduras, es importante recalcar que
las cosas pueden cambiar y suelen cambiar.
Ahí tenemos, por ejemplo, el caso de Colombia.
Mientras tanto mucho ánimo.
Y ahora turno para ti, ¿Crees que estamos
ante un golpe de Estado?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo no
olvides darle a like.
Un saludo y hasta
la próxima.